okay so i like the idea of dabbling
stuff that's not strictly comic books
and recently i started watching avatar
the last airbender now the whole reason
why i started watching this is my fiance
is a massive avatar the last airbender
fan like literally i can blindfold her
and just start a random episode and she
could tell me exactly what's going on in
that episode right she lives breathes
and eats avatar the last airbender and
honestly given how many times i've just
walked in on her re-watching the show
i've more or less seen all the episodes
but i haven't like sat down and digested
the episodes you know what i mean like i
haven't like totally understood what was
going on so i decided to sit down and
watch it right start watching avatar the
last airbender and uh and there's a few
things about this show like one i
understand it's not a anime in the
traditional sense it doesn't really
originate from japan but it does have
like anime themes you can kind of feel
it a little bit in the show brandon i'm
not the most knowledgeable when it comes
to anime my knowledge of anime is is
limited to like
dragon ball
and like full metal alchemist
brotherhood which mariah made me watch
and
i think that's it
i don't think there's any other ones but
this show's got some pretty cool stuff
season one was boring as hell right i'm
just gonna throw it out there i'm sorry
for all you avatar fans season one was
boring right
it took everything in me to get myself
through that show but where i kept
making a really good point and saying
that it's all just world building right
the whole basis behind season one is to
introduce you to characters and all that
kind of stuff so you can kind of go
forward from there and then sort of do
your own thing right kind of understand
everything that's happening in seasons
two through three i'm part way through
season two i skipped over the episode
about oppa's lost days i saw that
episode with mariah that was so sad man
i don't want to watch oppa go through
hell like i don't want to see that right
where oppa is just like having a rough
time it's like the avatar last airbender
equivalent of like the commercials with
sarah mclaughlin right in the arms of an
angel and like the little the saw the
sad dog eyes and all that kind of stuff
like every year dogs you know this and
like you just turn it off it's that but
avatar the last airbender i don't want
to watch that so like i skipped over
that episode they're they're the
characters though the characters are
intriguing to me right uh katara pisses
me off she's annoying right she's always
like happiness and clouds and sunshine
and everything will be okay and then
toff is badass dude i love toff oh my
god dutoff is amazing she's like this
super hardcore no-nonsense woman mariah
told me toff gets amazing in legend of
korra and she told me guitar gets really
really cool at the end of the series
something about blood bending or
something like that i don't know but
it's like it's it's really really cool
she told me guitar gets it's really
awesome saka obviously is like the the
comic relief right whatever um and then
and then right ang is interesting i know
enough about avatar to understand
there's a lot of differentiations and
like debates out there between like aang
and korra which one's better that like
cora was basically being trained to be
an avatar as best they could even though
they kept her sheltered but she was
still incompetent but aang was like this
kid who was frozen for like a hundred
years and then like literally was flying
by the seat of his pants the whole time
became like one of the best avatars ever
and then there's zuko right now here's
the thing about zuko right like i
understand now why people say zuko has
like the best character arc in the
history of like animation right dude
zuko is legit uh here's a crazy thing
that episode what was it um zuko alone i
think is what it was when he went like
he like left uncle iro which uncle iro
is awesome dude i love uncle iro man
he's so cool like i just want to hang
out with uncle ira and just be like hey
man like tell me tell me about how you
see stuff although it was kind of
tear-jerking when like he goes to like
the the place where his son's buried and
like sings that little song right like
please falling and it's just like i was
just like damn man
you get what i mean it's it's a little
rough right it's a little rough on the
fields you know it's it's a little it
hits it just hits differently you know
so so you know zuko alone that was that
i think was probably one of the coolest
episodes and mariah kept telling me that
she kept saying that like zuko alone is
probably the best character the best
episode for the character of zuko and i
totally get that now because for zuko
and and honestly i feel like you can
kind of see the progression by the end
of season one right but like and maybe
not even really i guess
it's it's interesting right so let's
let's break this down like a fraction
right so so zuko i love the character of
zuko because when you're first
introduced to him he's just like i gotta
make my dad proud right like his dad's a
dick he's done really nothing to make
zuko's life great he literally burned
half his face right so it's like he's
like i want to make my dad proud so i
can urge my dad's on and all that kind
of stuff that's the driving force behind
his life right it's just it's the thing
that drives zuko earning his dad's
respect and he's like constantly chasing
after the avatar and unlike what you
would expect with like harry potter or
something like that like witnessing the
kindness of aang led zuko to change his
ways and just like the grinch his heart
grew three sizes bigger and it's not
like that instead it's almost like it
comes from uncle iro and like his own
personal experiences right that ira is
always kind of imparting these pearls of
wisdom they're like hey your dad's only
as relevant as you allow him to be right
like if your dad has no value to you
then your dad has no value to you and
that's it right like there's more to
this life than trying to make your pops
proud especially when your pops is a
dick that's literally trying to conquer
the world so uh ultimately he kind of
goes forward does his own thing and then
you get to zuko alone and i feel like
that's really the first time that zuko's
exposed to like what the fire nation
really is about right in the sense that
it's like okay he's out there he's
helping these people fight off what's
supposed to be an army protecting them
but they've basically just descended
into bandits right because who's gonna
stop them right the townspeople don't
have the balls to do it and then as soon
as zuko like reveals his identity that
like he's prince zuko the fire nation
the whole town they just protected turns
against him like they're just like get
out of here like even the little kid
like the little kids just like get out
of here man i don't want to have
anything to do with you and the little
kid loves zuko right he thought he was
the coolest thing ever right and i think
i feel like that's the first time zuko
really grasps just how the fire nation
is perceived by the rest of the world
and i think like that's really when zuko
starts to change now granted i'm not far
enough in the show to know exactly how
zuko progresses as the show goes on i
know he ends up turning against his
father later on right that much i know
but i'm not far enough in to really
grasp how things progress and how things
change man but i got to tell you dude
avatar the last airbender man like i
thought it was goofy right like a kids
show like when when like mariah would
watch it i'm like why are you watching
this is a show for kids right it's
nonsense man there's some adult themes
in this show man like i totally
understand how so many of you guys grew
up with this show
and you're like yeah yeah
avatar is the greatest three i totally
understand that you know how you guys
how you guys love that now i mean it's
it's a cool show like it's an it's an
interesting show and i'm digging it
right i'm definitely digging this what
i'm really curious about here
is like the progression of aang right
like the whole idea of aang and like
where he ends up being at because one of
the things that i've learned so far and
specifically i learned from zuko and
honestly it reaffirms the philosophy
that i always held before violence is
not always the answer that's true right
violence is not always the answer there
are always other answers besides
violence however violence is a answer
and it's usually a very effective one so
you know it kind of reaffirms
that belief that i have right uh but
it's cool right i'm i'm really curious
to see how ink pos how hang progresses
and how aim changes now here's a
question that i have for all you guys
out there who are huge avatar the last
airbender fans what's up with kiyoshi
because mariah was recently reading a
book called the rise of kyoshi i think
it was and like there's a kiyoshi
warriors all that kind of stuff which is
weird soccer's girlfriend became the
moon
and i don't even know how that happens
but like she became i saw it but i still
i walked away from it like i don't fully
understand this like she's the
embodiment of the moon spirit or like
she absorbs the moon spirit into herself
or something i don't i don't i don't
know i don't fully grasp it but whatever
it is man like i mean how many guys you
know who can walk around and say my
girlfriend became the moon right i mean
most people would just think you're like
a schizophrenic rather just be like okay
buddy uh
you stay over there but with regards to
to kyoshi give me the rundown on this
because i did get a bit of an
explanation even now it still kind of
confuses me a little bit but as i
understand it from how it was explained
to me by mariah that kyoshi is just this
ridiculously amazing avatar who was an
avatar before like long before aang and
all that right like the kyoshi warriors
and all that kind of stuff are all
modeled after the idea
of her as an avatar uh from what i can
tell she seems super powerful honestly i
find it much easier to relate the
avatars to like jedi and like wielders
of the force to understand how powerful
they are right so like aang is powerful
ain't like like i don't know anakin at
his peak and like hiyoshi is like
exarcoon just like unbridled force
unleashed right like the ground just
shakes beneath her feet i don't know if
that's really the case
i don't know if that's that's really
what's going on but give me some info
guys give me some right now i know this
has nothing to do with marvel or dc or
whatever i don't care right this is geek
culture explained i can talk about
whatever i want to so let me know what
you guys think down in the comments your
stance on avatar the last airbender do
you love it do you think it's
whatever but i'm digging it the earth
kingdom like the earth kingdom emperor
that guy's a [ __ ] dude that guy man
he's he's like the biggest punk ever man
i'm just like like dude like are you an
emperor or not because you're basically
like the the like the guy
in the in your entire empire right like
you can literally just point to a person
and say they have to die and they will
die right you are kind of like god among
your people right and like you've got
some so what is it the dile just like
whisper in his ear manipulating him i'm
like grow some balls man get some balls
dude and like be an emperor man because
right now you're just being a punk but
let me know what you guys think down in
the comments section about avatar the
last airbender the show is really cool
i'm pretty invested in it so far and i
will catch you all later
peace